bonsoir françois durpaire merci d'être
avec nous évidemment scrutin décisif en
qui se tient aujourd'hui aux états unis
qui doit donc décider de la majorité au
sénat
élection majeure pour l'avenir du pays
oui il ya en fait trois enjeux le
premier enjeu c'est l'agenda législatif
de joe biden si le sénat et républicains
et bien vous imaginez bien que en
matière d'écologie en matière de justice
sociale en matière économique la
politique de joe biden ne sera pas la
même
il sera en cohabitation la deuxième
chose c'est très immédiat c'est la
domination cabinet pour nommer son
cabinet son ministère à bien il faut
avoir la validation du sénat
et rappelez-vous que mitch mcconnell qui
était le chef des républicains au sénat
et bien avait donné du fil à retordre à
barack obama il avait fallu onze mois
onze mois de blocage donc pour la
nomination du cabinet et puis un
troisième enjeu qui est ça on va suivre
ça avec beaucoup d'attention
c'est le degré de confiance du peuple
américain à l'égard de sa démocratie
léger revient vont-ils voter vont-ils
voter dans ce contexte où on leur dit
les élections sont truquées l'élection
présidentielle était truqué
cette élection on peut vous la voler 68%
des républicains sont d'accord avec deux
mains trump pour dire cette élection
présidentielle a été volé donc voilà ce
sont les trois enjeux d'un scrutin qui
vous le voyez beaucoup plus importants
que le simple deuxième tour d'une
élection sénatoriale dans un état mais
alors c'est vrai que françois durpaire
nous nous sommes habitués à notre
système français où traditionnellement
souvent après l'élection présidentielle
on a tendance à donner la majorité au
parlement au président pour qu'il puisse
mener ses réformes le programme qu'il a
promis pendant sa campagne
aux etats unis ce n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose si on comprend bien ou
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
parce que la vote dans un deuxième tour
en géorgie c'est la règle parce que
aucun candidat n'a passé le cap des 50%
donc il faut faire un deuxième tour
d'ordinaire
lorsqu'il ya un deuxième tour c'est
plutôt favorable au parti républicain
pourquoi parce que il ya généralement
plus de républicains qui se mobilisent
dans ce type d'élections locales
mais là il ya quand même quelque chose
de très différent c'est que la georgie
n'a pas été gagné par donald trump
c'est la première fois depuis trente ans
que la georgie et gagné par à démocrate
et ses princes abc d'ailleurs tous les
sondages
vous avez entendu les reportages sont
dans la la marge d'erreur léger avantage
aux républicains mais que s'est il passé
depuis novembre est ce que les
républicains vont se déplacer parce que
je vous ai dit soit 100% 68% des
républicains sont d'accord avec donald
trump ça veut dire que tous les autres
ne sont pas nécessairement d'accord avec
deux attrapés et la nouveauté depuis
quelques semaines c'est que le parti
républicain est divisée on le verra
cette fois après demain on va peut-être
en reparler au congrès pour la
certification de la victoire de joe
biden et bien cette division du parti va
t-elle se retrouver sur le terrain dans
une division des électeurs avec une
partie des électeurs qui ne se
déplacerait pas vous voyez c c'est
extrêmement ouvert justement vous
parliez de cette étape n'a pas gagné
donald trump lui en tout cas il continue
à dire le contraire on a vu cette vidéo
publiée par le washington post qui a
fait beaucoup parler de notre homme
accusé de faire pression sur le
secrétaire d'état de géorgie pour qu'il
vous trouve entre guillemets ces
fameuses 12000 voit comment réagit sur
ce point le camp républicain cette
attitude de donald trump
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
de voir effectivement ce qu'en pense
notamment les sénateurs et les
représentants républicains parce que
après marc mercredi ils vont devoir se
prononcer si la deuxième date importante
de la semaine américaine le 5 dont
l'élection en géorgie et le 6 la
certification des votes par le sénat et
vous savez qu'il ya 13
sénateur d'accord avec donald trump pour
dire cette élection a été truquée nous
allons contester ces sénateurs se
retrouvent autour de tes cruz le
sénateur bien connu du texas et de josh
hall et mais il y à des républicains qui
ne sont pas d'accord et il ya déjà 21
sénateurs républicains qui ont dit à
nous on s'opposera absolument à cette
tentative
nous voterons la certification pour joe
battat j'ai bien ma sénateurs celui
d'oklahoma qui dit bien si je ne devais
pas certifié joe biden ce serait en
quelque sorte violer son serment de deux
sénateurs donc on peut s'attendre
mercredi à a2 finalement à des
oppositions à l'intérieur du parti
républicain pression du président des
états unis mais vous voyez qu'une partie
les républicains et même majoritaire
pour l'instant est bien est hostile à la
tentative de non certification des votes
ça laisse présager de ce qui se passera
après on a dit que denain trappe était
quelqu'un qui avait une grosse influence
chez les conservateurs parce qu'il a
fait un score très important à plus de
soixante dix millions de voix mais vous
voyez que lorsque donald trump est en
passe de partir et bien déjà au sein du
parti républicain il ya une partie des
voix et bien qu'ils s'expriment pour
dire il faut tourner la page
justement françois à quoi doit-on
s'attendre pour la suite concernant
donald trump parce que on voit il
poursuit évidemment une stratégie
le président américain sortant une
pensons là sont ni déjà 2024 selon vous
oui on
il ya beaucoup de raisons qui font que
donne un tram veut rester au coeur de
l'actualité et y a quand même quelque
chose à dire c'est que avant que d'un
simple choix candidat victorieux
il a été candidat quatre choix en tout
cas il a laissé entendre qu'il serait
candidat quatre fois l'élection
présidentielle dire que l'élection
présidentielle dans la vie de donald
trump a compté y compris dans ses
affaires pour rester au coeur de cette
actualité
alors là il va pas sortir de l'actualité
il a plus d'abonnés
twitter par exemple que le président
américain élu joe biden alors c'est pas
anecdotique un twitter c'est pas juste
pour s'amuser c'est de la communication
politique
chacun des messages de donald trump sera
re tweeté à des dizaines de milliers à
des centaines de milliers parfois de
bien de supporter qui continueront à le
soutenir
2024 peut-être mais avant 2024
quel va être l'impact politique de d'un
train vous savez einsenhower disait un
homme politique il tient sa force dans
le fait qu'un grand nombre de citoyens
le crois et beaucoup de citoyens
américains croient donald trump la
moitié du peuple américain et plus même
crois que c'est un menteur
mais l'autre moitié du peuple américain
pense que c'est le seul à dire la vérité
en tout cas on l'aura compris redonne un
train de place le pays dans un état plus
tôt de diviser vous venez encore de le
rappeler
enrique tario le leader d'époque dont
les arrières une milice d'extrême droite
fidèles à donald trump a été arrêté son
arrestation qui survient donc alors que
deux journées de mobilisation en faveur
de trames sont prévues à washington s
on doit s'attendre aux états unis à une
montée des tensions ces prochains mois
alors on a vu déjà des tensions
s'exprimer y compris dans la rue au
cours des dernières semaines entre
partisans de donald trump et adversaires
de m à ces tensions n'ont pas débouché
sur deux de détention extrêmement grave
on n'a pas eu à déplorer dans tout le
pays
des oppositions vraiment très très
massives on peut penser qu'avec
l'arrivée de joe biden finalement la
politique américaine reprenne son cours
ce pays c'est un éternel recommencement
de désir de volonté et d'efforts
d'unités ils s'appellent les états unis
d'amérique
donc il faut peut-être faire confiance
dans cette démocratie américaine
peut-être que la nouveauté c'est celle
dont on parlait il ya quelques secondes
c'est ce rapport à la vérité la division
il y en a toujours eu il ya eu des
guerres culturelles dans l'histoire
américaine
pensez aux années 60 c'est pas nouveau
la division
ou du peuple américain mais en revanche
sur cette question de la vérité certains
croient certains médias d'autres ont
d'autres médias ou se penchent
simplement sur les réseaux sociaux
les théories du complot sont de plus en
plus partagée et on le voit notamment on
n'a pas parlé ce soir du coronavirus
mais c'est vraiment la grande affaire
aujourd'hui aux états unis avec des
ralentissements notamment beaucoup
d'américains qui se disent on ne va pas
assez vite dans la vaccination la
campagne de vaccination et d'autres
américains qui disent dans ce vaccin est
très très mauvais et négatif
donc c'est vraiment la grande question
peut-être de ce début de xxième siècle
aux états unis
la question de la post vérité merci
françois défaire pour votre analyse
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france